hey this is ian terry from big brother
all stars and this is my et
post eviction interview by a vote
of five to three ian
you are evicted from the big brother
house
hey again good game
[Music]
i felt like i was definitely going to uh
definitely going to be losing the voter
or at least was very likely to lose the
vote
uh probably around late tuesday night
early wednesday
that being said i did have athletic
shoes ready to go on the side in case i
did get the votes
so uh it wasn't uh oh i'm giving up
the fact i was dressed up just was i
wanted to dress up and
if i did stay i would have been ready to
go and play
in my man i am in an alliance called the
committee
it's myself cody memphis danny
christmas and nicole they all promised
to vote for me
[Music]
i mean frankly uh i'm not gonna look
down on good gameplay
i would much much rather lose because i
got outfoxed by
good players than because i got unlucky
that's just how i am it's way easier to
live with that
than if i just got really unlucky and
lost
if someone plays well and i lose so be
it
that's just the way it should go
i actually was a bit surprised by that
um frankly i
i am in a way kind of happy that uh
both of the winners uh evaded nomination
for quite a long time
um so that was at least good
um i know for a while we we were joint
record holding uh now nicole has that
record to herself
as far as evading nomination as a
previous winner um
but overall pretty happy with how that
was
going
i think that the house could use a
little bit of a shake-up
just to keep things competitive so if
cody were to join me in the jury
house i think that would be a really
exciting uh
really exciting sequence so kind of
hoping that that happens just to keep
things
interesting i don't want it to just be a
uh
you know railroad out of everybody that
isn't in the committee
this might be one of the closer votes
but i
literally didn't think that that's the
hardest part it's what it is
i mean i just i don't i just don't want
to go
oh my god i know it's my fault like
honestly like you should blame me and
like i will
i think this time around was way more
difficult than my original season
um and i think a large part of the
reason is just uh
one the caliber of play on average is
much stronger
in this all-stars cast and two
uh the fact that everybody is pretty
agreeable and
i got along with um
everyone made it harder because uh it's
it's much more difficult to vote out
people you like
um as opposed to in my original season
it was
quite easy to vote off some folks
because i plain disliked them
[Music]
i think that uh realistically i would
have to go all the way back to week one
and find some way to ensure that i was
in the large alliance the way big
brother is you just want to be in the
large alliance when it forms in the
early goings
um if you're not in you're gonna have a
really uphill battle
so um frankly i i would have to just
go all the way back and find a way to
get in there